always carries his gun when he leaves
home he says he's been attacked four
times for campaigning against illegal
logging
despite dangers he stops to investigate
when he sees logs of wood
there's so much illegal logging how will
a forest survive this area in which we
are talking used to be a natural forest
but the trees have been chopped off to
convert this into a rubber plantation
the northeast is home to nearly a
quarter of all forests in india and also
some of its greatest biodiversity but
changing methods of farming natural
disasters and growing populations have
significantly reduced it
morant lawyer number has been preserving
this patch of land in the state of
manipur he started growing plants on a
hill two decades ago now it's a lush
forest that boasts of dozens of plant
and animal species every season there
was three four wildfires to come and uh
you know the destroy the whole place so
uh initially the like i used to clear
clear clear all the lantern i use the
plant and slowly i found
other
trees which used to be there it started
growing also
officials say they need to balance
environmental concerns with
developmental needs plantations like
these have become a popular way to do it
probably after 50 years we'll have a
natural forest as we are having in this
part of area so we have to start
somewhere so that was a solution which
was not perfect but it was better than
having nothing
the government says these efforts are
paying off and its recent report shows
forests are growing but some experts are
skeptical what it does is
it equates natural forests
with plantations now plantations could
be monoculture plantations
plantations could be rubber plantations
it could be apple orchards all of that
so this is it's important to distinguish
there are laws and policies to protect
forests in india but many
conservationists like georgio tanatara
believe there's little political will to
enforce them
bhavni mithal al-jazeera new delhi